I think budget might actually be my
favorite day of the year is not normally
for the kind of geeky reasons that you
might expect although yeah it is news
there's stuff happening but really the
real reason I get excited is because
normally these guys the gallery these
are the kind of directors who actually
kind of decide what's going on screen
normally they control what's going on
with our big screen and all of the
graphics and I have to just kind of
pretty much follow orders today is the
one day of the year actually autumn
statement as well but the Wonder the
year where I actually have control in my
hands of what happens on this big screen
I can tell you how exciting it is to
have power over such a big thing here
and it means that basically over the
course of the day come up and have a
look at some of the grafts we're going
to be showing over the course the day we
can kind of explore what is going on in
the economy and tell the story of it um
and we can do it in a slightly more kind
of involved way than we normally do on
any given story so if you want to look
at how the world economy is doing we
have the graph for you if you want to
look at what the expectations are for
inflation in the next few years we can
do that too if you want to look at kind
of different measures and how much
things are going to cost we can do all
of that and the remarkable thing from my
perspective from a selfish perspective
is that I can control it all just have a
look at this I'm going to pick out one
of these measures what street let's quit
kind of government spending the pie
chart can you see that that little
button and I'm going to press it bang
and look at the screen there it is it's
like the most exciting big iPad you've
ever heard of and I have control of it
for at least a few hours until the
directors in there get a bit upset and
they take it back from me